EA's new Monster Hunter like game wild
Hearts doesn't technically release until
later this week on February 17th but if
you're eager to jump in sooner AKA right
now you can do so and try out the game's
opening hours here's the catch you need
an active membership on Game Pass
ultimate or EA play and you have to have
a PC because this trial is only for the
PC game pass players this early access
trial lasts for 10 hours or up until you
reach the city Gates of monado
Impressions from The Game's early trials
seem to be positive on the gameplay
front but a look at the wild hard
subreddit shows a long list of
performance related complaints an
official response from the dev states it
is working to improve performance and
optimization specifically on PC a patch
is slated to arrive next week that
should address the CPU bottleneck
problem the team says that it has
discovered which should improve
performance across mid high-end CPUs EA
play is five bucks for one month or 30
dollars for a year while Game Pass
ultimate is 15 bucks but you get EA play
baked into your subscription and in
other game pass news Microsoft has
clarified its own admission that putting
games on Xbox game pass can in some
cases lead to a decrease in sales in a
statement of Gamespot a Microsoft
spokesperson said Microsoft tries to
help game developers make the most money
they possibly can through Game Pass as
such Microsoft Cuts deals with
developers and Publishers on a title by
title basis the terms of which are not
made public and are presumably not
consistent across the board in its
statement Microsoft didn't comment
specifically on any cannibalization
effect but it also didn't say this never
happens given the size and scale of Xbox
game pass the custom Financial
agreements for each game and all matter
of other potential contributing factors
it certainly seems that some Xbox game
pass titles would see their full game
sales affected by being included in the
service in other cases however game
sales May grow over time thanks to being
included in Game Pass in the comments
let me know how has Game Pass changed
your purchasing habits are you the type
that maybe will buy a month try the game
cancel your subscription and then buy
the game outright or are you the type of
gamer that will hold off on buying a
game altogether just to see if it
eventually shows up on Game Pass let me
know a game that's still waiting
patiently for its possible Game Pass
debut is Modern Warfare 2. the military
Sims new season is arriving tomorrow
February 15th and it includes new
weapons a brand new battle pass a new
raid episode and four more maps the
standard ones include dome which is
originally from Modern Warfare 3 but was
also featured in Vanguard the other is
Valderas Museum my favorite from the
beta period that was quietly removed
from the game upon release while
mazura's Zaya Observatory and al-malik
international locations will serve as
the two new maps for ground war and
invade modes when it comes to new modes
you can expect Call of Duty's hardcore
mode to return this season as well as
other Classics like gun game and
infected Treyarch's competitive ranked
play will make an appearance at the
launch of season 2 but fans of modes
like all or nothing or One in the
Chamber will have to wait for later in
the season for more on what to expect
from the update head on over to
gamespot.com got any Valentine's Day
plans let me know in the comments and uh
you know I'll keep my ear out for uh
doorbell just in case you were sending
me some chocolates or flowers or teddy
bears you know stuff like that I'll uh
I'll keep I'll keep listening thanks in
advance
thank you